by the end of this year this will be a
Christmas present in the form of 5
billion
Euro this is not a small
gift this is very important
funds that uh will be
used to improve our energy
sovereignty and we will do our utmost to
spend this money in the proper
manner and
uh I will ask
our Minister of Justice following the
formal procedures in the Polish
parliament in the
same we will also try to become members
of the European prosecutor's
office this is very important this is a
signal that uh we are taking the issues
of the rule of law very
seriously also when it comes to the
proper uh use of EU
funds and this is something very
important following the change in
Poland thank you for your trust once
again I would like to thank you very
very
much thank you for everything you have
done and I have to
say that uh there must be mutual trust
and there is mutual trust there is even
personal
friendship and this facilitates work and
cooperation this is about uh restoring
the
rules uh related to the rule of law
without this the European commission
would not have taken this decision so
once again thank you very much to all
those who made it
possible thank
you
[Music]
just